we are the land of the free the home of
the brave
across the world face masks are the new
normal i don't think i'm going to be
doing it
i'm just trying to keep myself and my
community safe as well
but while most countries have
anti-masters nowhere are they more
prominent
and more political than the usa so why
do some americans have a problem with
wearing masks
the u.s has seen the highest number of
covert deaths and cases in the world
and yet about a third of states still
have no mandate to wear masks while in
public
the specifics vary from state to state
but the message is the same
it's recommended to wear a mask the
world health organizations back this up
it's asked countries to make mask
wearing a normal part
of being around other people while for
many americans wearing a mask is just
part of life now
you know you're not just leaning for
yourself you're doing it for others as
well
for others wearing face coverings goes
beyond public health concerns
this is about freedom it's about america
this is about opening
our country if you want to wear a mask
wear a mask
but don't make somebody else do it that
is not america
that is not freedom it's become a sign
of your political affiliation
the country is extremely divided right
now and unfortunately people are using
and politicizing whatever they can kind
of get their hands on that slightly out
of the norm
mask is not a political statement
but it is a good way to start pulling
the country together
this is voluntary i don't think i'm
going to be doing it
president trump's attitude towards
wearing masks as well as the pandemic
more broadly has informed the views of
many of his followers
i don't wear mess like him every time
you see him he's got a mask he could be
speaking
200 feet away from it he shows up with
the biggest mask i've ever seen
72 percent of people who think wearing
mask is a personal choice
voted for trump in the presidential
election now how about california though
where you're supposed to eat
with the mass can't take it out the
majority of states that haven't mandated
mask wearing voted republican
and states with mass mandates mostly
voted democrat
a mask remains the most potent weapon
against the virus
i don't believe the scientific evidence
to show that the mask will stop anybody
from getting anything because it's a
virus
and a virus is a smaller particle than
what a mass can stop
making face coverings mandatory in
public spaces across the us
could be one of joe biden's first acts
as president
an act that wouldn't go down well with
the anti-masters
because america is not about communism
it's not about you know put
forcing everybody to put on these masks
for the safety
of you know the safety of everybody it's
about protecting our freedoms
their jobs the politicians jobs are to
actually protect our freedoms
this all goes a long way back americans
have been rebelling against central
authority since the boston tea party
they didn't like england's taxes then
and took matters into their own hands
that rebellion was enshrined a few years
later in the constitution which
guarantees the basic
freedoms of citizens and it's something
the anti-masters use frequently to
defend their actions
but in reality the constitution does not
back up these choices
the supreme court sees the protection of
public health as reason enough
to infringe on the first amendment
online conspiracy communities that
question if covert is real may also be
playing a role in why
some americans don't want to wear masks
whether it's downplaying the virus as
just the flu
crediting symptoms to 5g towers or
denying its existence completely
these communities have been posting to
convince people to ditch safety
proportions
set out by authority figures the
question now is will the new president
be able to change enough people's minds
will he be able to convince americans
that a mask isn't a political symbol
it's just a mask and will that in turn
help bring down the spread of the virus